you screwed up she has a problem that
she can't get past it so here's what
should have happened you shouldn't
mention that she had smaller breasts in
the first six months but I understand
you want to be honest if she laid it and
I've had this right am i perfect is
there anything about me that you would
change it's a setup
run name time dear Steven I'm a 26 year
old male and I've had the same
girlfriend for two and a half years now
she's 22 I wish to marry this girl one
day I have known her since very long I'm
deeply in love with everyone okay okay
we communicate very well we have very
similar values when it comes to morals
politics and religion we both enjoyed
working out staying active being fit
healthy although are interested for
greatly and how we do that what matters
is she cares enough to take care of
herself and look good the first of all
cause that's not what matters primarily
but like yeah you know we both you know
we're both Christians well it's just
same values but she's got a great set of
dick she ain't never gonna lose him I
mean everyone SiC transit gloria gloria
fades so do breasts mmm that was latin I
didn't know the Latin word for breasts
well next time do some research I know
Gloria fate I have seen your skits and
heard you talk about what women think
men talk about when it comes to finding
them attractive this has been the only
major point of constants of contention
between us and our relationship she
thinks that I do not find her attractive
she does not look like the stereotypical
American model this is her she has small
breasts now I feel bad about the joke
but not really and I made a comment
towards this the first six months in our
relation okay it's tough to overcome
them but you can you can for six months
even if it's some of this really
bothering if you're like this is the one
except for that you wait a little bit
and you know you find a brochure in the
mail where it's half off
you don't just mention that first thing
you just blurt it's like it's like a
Christmas story blurt not about the BBU
seeing Chris Lea bears buy plastic candy
store
okay and I made a comment about this in
the first six months of relationship
that is never that has manifested and
grown into an ugly monster that I would
have never envisioned the comment was
something like and he writes this out of
the script her
do you like my boobs oh me yes I like
them a lot and then in parenthesis many
other compliments then dot dot dot in
parentheses trigger button sorry again
this is this is the email then where I
stop quote maybe they could be a little
bit oh okay and this a monster was born
first off you come back you could
probably be a writer compare developed
from a heavy monthly discussion into a
weekly fight and now a daily one to the
point where she messages me big long
paragraphs and essays about how she is
not my ultimate physical preference mind
you this is only concerning her boobs I
have spent countless nights staying up
till midnight
to get nowhere with her just to midnight
she believes it the only way she's going
to feel loved is if she gets constant
words of affirmation detailing specifics
why I love her boobs more than all other
people I don't know that that's possible
to say rapunzel Rapunzel you have the
fairest mirror mirror on the wall yes
who has the best funbags of them all I
mean you have to say although all boobs
I'm either
even if she were you know like there's
someone out there who we haven't seen
yet yeah kind of like the best
basketball player we don't know it's not
LeBron it really quiet ears everyone we
were deal with with with disabled
veterans thing about suicide everyone's
odd comfortable now because of a guy who
mentioned is I feel like this guy or two
years ago this guy set a noose up for
himself and he's just been tightening it
ever said okay I got have to finish I
tell I tell her that you are my ultimate
physical attraction because I am in love
with you she tries to force me to
separate the physical from the emotional
to say that she is not my ultimate
preference and comment about what it is
about her boobs at lack attractive
qualities I tell her I don't even know
if I like bigger boobs in yours the ones
that I have had past experiences with I
didn't like more than your smaller ones
don't bring up past
now let's get use the objective smaller
yes just say I don't even know just say
I don't know I don't just say here's how
that could go right like I love your
boobs I have nothing to compare them I
don't have anything compare them to the
bass that's all I see first off this is
a joke I don't know if this is real
because there are a couple things I'll
get into here and then we'll wrap this
up right I tell her she ages she's going
to look stunning because she won't have
[Laughter]
don't care about the future is that I
was was your ultimate physical
preference so I know I've come a long
ways about the subject of this email by
now but all this conflict came about
when we started having sex I guess my
question is well do you think we brought
this problem upon ourselves on by having
sex before marriage I know this point is
probably and something that keeps going
going on okay first off jail I have a
bunch of opinions here what's your read
so I think there's a number of things
that you can kind of run through here
first off yes I think having sex before
marriage does something that it
shouldn't do to you right it focuses you
on a physical part of the relationship
that you don't need to be focusing on
before you've developed all the other
parts of your relationship together and
I think that's one of the biggest one
your case don't - wait yeah here's the
thing - but both of you guys are
spending way too much time so look I
think as you I want to kill Stephen so
many no look it you're I'm not a boob
guy I'm going somewhere all right I'm
not a boob guy but if I were a boob guy
I wouldn't judge a girl based on her
breasts that's not what you should judge
somebody on because no matter what no
matter what you have as your thing
that's going to change okay anything
else don't judge the one in the physical
appearance you have anything else yeah
but he's not he's obviously he is oh he
is it that's what you're saying okay
first off you screwed up okay you
screwed up by saying this with me first
off if it wasn't a prophet but was not a
problem for you
don't bring it up but if you're just
pointing out that she has small breasts
you're just being an ass so
I think that your this was a dumb
comment to make I agree with Gerald yeah
particularly as you said you've had
experience without the breasts I think
that if you're having a lot of sex
relationships before you get married to
listen think of two pieces of tape right
this is analogous they're sticky and you
rip them apart right you have each
person here and haven't sexually keep
ripping it apart it's that salt and help
sudden the tapes no longer sticky right
you have it's not necessarily a good
thing people think test drive all the
cars we talked about this earlier about
about orgasms about people who wait
until May they have far more uh
fulfilling sex lives they have sex more
on average listen this is these are
statistical realities I can make the
argument to wait until you're married
just don't don't have sex before he
married so you don't get some kind of
disease and emaciate like Tom Hanks in
Philadelphia but the truth is there are
a lot of reasons why it's beneficial as
far as this I will say you made a
mistake okay you repeated the mistake
when you talked about her smaller
comparing other breasts to her smaller
ones that being said she also sounds
like a psycho I would imagine that both
of you are very respected very vain yeah
so it seems to me that you would make
this comment because you're very vain
person and she picks up on the fact that
you're a very vain person and so it
really bothers her she thinks she'll
never be happy because of your vanity
and she feels as though she's not
perfect my guess is that's what's
happening right now there's there some
kind of triple levels deep of projection
going on because it's not especially
like I said if she's attractive if you
love her if you find her attractive
listen nobody's perfect no okay and you
need to get in you but you need to be
able to get past this so it sounds like
this is not a relationship that's going
to be conducive toward a long-term one
men are getting married to this and this
is still constantly coming up you
screwed up she has a problem that she
can't get past it so here's what should
have happened you shouldn't mention that
she had smaller breasts in the first six
months but I understand you want to be
honest if she laid it and I've had this
right am i perfect is there anything
about me that you would change it's a
setup run negative every time
here's what I always tell people your
husband wants to see you naked we don't
you're probably not perfect everyone
here of everyone that we are married to
or engage to there's probably something
that we would change about you
physically if we had a Photoshop right
and just hit shift this a little bit
okay right scale it maybe don't hit
shift maybe we do the whole kind of Tim
Burton vibe I have no idea
but we're point is every single thing
one of us here we have something that
would change physically no one who says
that is not the case is lying because
you're not perfect just like I know I'm
not perfect right just like all of us
know we're not perfect you think that
all your women think that you're perfect
no no you're not red spark okay um
that being said she can't seem to get
passes I think it's because she's
picking up on your vanity there's some
level that but either way she does have
to get past it yeah if you want to get
me this you're gonna at some point in
time say this is this is either going to
be a sticking point for the rest of our
lives
we're just gonna have to get past it
because I love you I want to see you
naked I'm attracted to you period okay
you're not gonna I don't want you
writing on a chalkboard 50 times that -
her boobs are better than all other boob
let me give you are you gonna end up kid
because if you can't handle this guess
what you're gonna be tried by someone
else by external factors let me give you
a prime example my wife is gorgeous my
wife has appeared every now and then in
video songs by accident and I've had
people that come and go oh yeah she's
pretty good she could use bigger tilt
those people guess what my wife goes
like yeah got small boobs I love them I
have no problem with it I'm not usually
I'm not a giant boob guy some people are
it doesn't matter I love my way it's not
perfect I'm not perfect my wit has some
physical scars so do i I want to see her
naked she wants to see me naked we want
to have sex with each other
we love each other that's really what
matters yeah right if my wife if like if
my wife and one poor is like there you
know you got one one ball looks a little
it looks different from the other like
one looks like one looks like it's like
a vertical Cadbury egg and one looks
like it's horizontal I'd go I guess I
never thought of it shall we continue
with their prior it's not that big of a
deal right now if it were something that
for example she were nitpicking about
saying like oh you know what you really
you really need to change your balls you
know whatever it is I have no idea I
really need to grow to get your biceps
bigger right I need bigger biceps oh you
really need a you really need to fix the
gray in your hair or something she can I
was in it for example my wife at one
point said you know you might want to
look younger since you kind of have
Gray's pretty young and I said you know
what no I'm just gonna go with it
and
this is this how it's gonna be and I
hope you and she said okay yeah now she
likes the gray hair that's fine see it
works out no one's perfect
but if you cannot get past this you're
not gonna get past the kind of crap that
other people will throw your way and
it's too late once two years of this by
the way that's that's a long time not to
be able to get over to some degree right
that's a long time you think at some
point they would they would be able to
like discuss it well I think if he's
been nitpicking like let me okay let me
ask you this are you getting into fights
right are getting into fights and every
now and then thrown in like a jab or
something like that like well no I'm
just bumping just mad cuz I'm hovering
cuz dinner was so small like you're cool
you know cuz we know how about we know
how to ID and I don't either when you
heard that and there did you you know
I'm wondering if you've brought it up or
alluded to in several always like have
you is this the only time you ever
brought it up was you she said am i /
and you said maybe your boobs could be a
little bit bigger which is stupid but
have you brought it up again since it
seems like it because either you have
which again is stupid many times over or
and by the way it could be and or she
sounds like she has real she has real
self-esteem issues that probably need be
worked out before this goes like the
same kind of major point when we're
talking about marriage don't marry a
project and don't improve yourself only
for the other person it's good when you
get married you'll find yourself
improving in ways that you didn't
necessarily anticipate because of the
other person showing you your blind
spots and that's a good thing
but your spouse shouldn't be the reason
you clean up your room your spouse
shouldn't be the reason you take care of
your health your spouse shouldn't be the
reason that you do a daily devotional
and keep your spiritual health line your
spouse should not be the reason that you
are driven and want to be successful in
business your spouse shouldn't be the
reason that you want to be a loyal good
friend and a stand-up guy who people can
rely on it shouldn't be your spot you
have to get this in order before you get
married to somebody because if someone
else on the opposite of the opposite sex
sex had all the problems I just listed
would you want to marry them and and
then if your answer to that is yes
that's because you're prot you probably
have self-esteem issues and you're
looking for someone who's down here so
you can feel as though you're above them
you want to marry somebody first if we
talk about being equally yoked right but
that things that nobody is perfectly
equally yoked that being said
if you're gonna if there's gonna be
discrepancy you want to try and marry up
you want to try and marry someone who's
gonna make you better than you are
someone who's not not someone for whom
you'll improve like I'm a complete loser
but I'll improve for her but someone who
will show you ways to improve right that
are more productive someone will be of
assistance to improving and becoming a
better person that's what you want to
marry I don't this is a miracle because
you're both managing to drag the other
person down but usually there's one
person but no come on no no no you get
back down here
somehow she's like it's like she's
dragging you down and then and then
you're climbing above her but then
you're like rockets and then she's
dragging you back down be the kind of
person that you would want to marry and
by the two women out there watch this is
not indicative of most men know you may
have small breasts you may have a large
but you may have a flat but you may you
may not have the perfect set of all the
parts you know what it doesn't matter it
really doesn't matter particularly if
you are already married to a man right
he doesn't sign on the dotted line at
that point if he's like well everything
else checks out except it's really gross
to see her naked yeah we don't expect it
to be perfect but I don't know what's
going on here
so hopefully that advice help listen man
look get smarter learn how you learn how
to deal with women better and I would
also maybe have person in a message to
send her side of the story because yeah
sounds like she's got some issues yes to
resolve it absolutely anything else you
want to say no no you covered though you
worse off from the generic PBS don't
judge someone by their appearance well I
was trying you interrupted a few times
dead gummit well I wasn't
Rumplestiltskin spinning gold it was a
woman who spent its pinnacle for some
years a needle that made her sleep right
yeah I don't know either way trouble
sells comas dick bet you he told his
wife that she had small breasts like
this video watch another one of our
videos or subscribe hit the notification
bell those don't really mean anything
anymore today in YouTube I would say hit
a like was a thumbs up but that might be
gone or comment below but that most
likely will be censored so bookmark the
page of course if you're using google
chrome they'll find a way to [ __ ] with
your bookmark so just join up at Lara's
credit com / mug Club that's lighter
with credit.com / mug Club you get a
hand - my
can you get access to the full daily
one-hour show and you're not beholden to
Susan Wojcicki / Clint Howard